I feel from question 3 so this is
question 3 and all the numbers that are
there I just read them into you so some
of you are to push is very it's
something or not but I want to show you
how powerful Excel you be and how much
work it can save your submission look up
for a second and once I teach you this
trick you can use it later on okay so
these are scores that are given to
difference I've got a minimum score of
one I think so seven eight nine and ten
okay now here's what I could do I could
manually go through and count how many
ones on it what did you use and so on
except some and I need you sitting in
front of a computer can do this for me
so pay close attention and if you want
you can go back to a spreadsheet and by
this time pilatus you can use it Excel
and all spreadsheet needs have functions
- cuttings so I'm gonna write C I'm
going to count however make all the
particular school there is it's useful
in truth I would say count here inside
this sense for certain I'm counting
inside this range of scores that I've
written down I want to know which one of
them has a smaller one okay so if you
type in count the if they will tell you
this inside
and when I first can talk it says to why
does this e to because this is to the -
I feel great now I can do the same thing
I'm just going to modify this in a way
that I've explained later if you like
just like before anytime you've got a
formula you can take that and you can
embed downwards
how do people smoke great there's just
that one right there all right when I go
down to the wall it's again counting for
me how many about five and seven and
eight and nine and ten isn't that a lot
easier than going through manually and
going through the count so so accurate
once I've got my exponent and my
frequency column what's why do I miss
their pot why support FX I'm going to
multiply across so I'm going to say
frequency x scores and once I've got
that copied I go all the way down so I
will show you again looks like it's very
very handy it it is cutting up here if
these cells mattress certain condition
in this case the blue thing is we've got
all those cells up there that's where I
want you to look in itself and then this
one is well check if it's 1 or checking
beats 3 or check the bits for so it
looks through all of them ok so all
these that phone over there if you like
well I can type that in down you can use
it or if you want to grab a picture of
it it's so super handy and you use it
all the time in the real world when you
try to actually count example without